[Musique]
c'est là qu'elle a noté
là
si ça va bien
[Musique]
ok on agit mais gilles simard en ce sens
avec parce qu'on a joué et joue ensemble
on est en affaires on est restées
parfois enfermés dans des eaux plus pu
sortir du théâtre parce qu'on restait
qu'à son réviser notre texte
voilà le jour jbc des italiennes voit la
lutte est âpre italienne des suédoises
direct moins de 3
moins de trois minutes yes avec
poussettes et est kevin aux médicaments
cabinet
j'adore ta caméra et on en direct dans
un assaut
non je lui dis un truc super moderne
oui ah bah tiens sert il s'est tu me
regardes ça je suis prêt et je n'arrive
bien sûr pas franchement je te jure il
m'a bien loire ya pas vraiment tu
faisais mais moderne et élégant à la
fois c'était vraiment des couleurs même
un temps d'arrêt et master
pas les femmes s
[Applaudissements]
chaque roue
[Musique]
ban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
je m'entraîne à torcy c'est quoi cette
tenue tu t'entraînes
regarde comme si
abdou diouf
[Musique]
vous
je ne veux pas changer
non
[Musique]
la mise en fond sonore
personne n'a tout
je
je jure également à mes rêves d'amour
avec warhol
[Musique]